Một mô thống mô trái mô trái mô trái tiết thỏa thuận đại được dựa tổng thống Mỹ
đô năng trâm và trụ tịch Trung Quốc tập cận bình giảm giảm các thằng thử
mạng sống phương. Theo đó, Mỹ sẽ giảm mô y粉 Trump thời quan với hàng
hóa Trung Quốc, đưa tổng mức thử từ năm 2019, suốt còn khoảng
4.5% đông thời hạ thử nhất cầu các sản phẩm đến quan đến phản tà nhiên từ
2020, 2019, Washington cũng tạm dừng một năm việc mở giống dành
sách lên các công ty công nghệ Trung Quốc và hoán áp dụng phi cạnh mấy
đổi với tàu măng cửa Trung Quốc. Fí Trung Quốc thì nhát tri tạm dừng các biển pháp
kiểm soát sất khẩu khoảng sản đất thì em và năm Trump.
Đông thời các dưới các trung trò việc sất khẩu gà li, cho mình đi,
ăn timon và thân chỉ, đây là động thái đứa xem là dựa bỏ thực tế
các biển pháp hạn chế đã áp dụng từ năm 2020.
Mặc kênh cùng sẹt đừng chỉ thấy đối ứng đối với hàng khoảng Mỹ,
Mỹ như lộ Mỹ, mô, lộn anh, thiết lợn và bỏ.
Đông thời chấm rất điều trà trung bản pha giá và trung lúc quyền với các dành nghiệp Mỹ trong ngành
bản giận. Mọi gia Trung Quốc cảm kết mùi ích nhất 12 triệu tấn độn anh,
Mỹ trong năm nay và 2 mấy lần triệu tấn 1 năm, trong và năm tửi,
đánh dấu bức tiên mới trong lỗ lực khôi phục nghiệm tiên thương mại,
dựa 2 những kinh tệ lần nhất gì thế giới.